foreign
[Music]
I did a podcast with you at the end of
September beginning of October and you
looked like a [ __ ] junkie like on the
streets that's a podcast you go to the
two fat cows podcast yeah yes I'm sorry
what's the name of our podcast two fat
cows
it's regular cows but fatter
today's Monday August 29th and sober
October is back Joe Rogan Tom Zagora
Bert Kreischer and Ari shaffir have
hinted on Instagram over the past couple
of days that sober October is set to
return this year they didn't do it last
year Rogan carried on the tradition by
himself but it seems like in just a few
weeks we're gonna get the sober October
crew back together for another challenge
it's already October
I'm scared let's just [ __ ] spark up a
joint what no it's fat blunt one of them
Backwoods now one of these Backwoods
these are so good
smell it just smell it whoa yeah welcome
back to the joke World comedy update
every single Monday bringing you the
comedy news that you need to know from
your favorite comedians your favorite
podcasts who went on each other's shows
last week any new specials coming out
any news with any comedian all in one
place so please consider subscribing to
joke world right now turning on the post
notifications and downloading this
episode on Spotify to support the
channel the return of sober October it
all started a few days ago when Bert
posted this picture on his Instagram
with the caption Hey Joe Rogan when I
hunt I don't use a bow I set traps see
who gets dealt with this sober October
and then tagged Joe Tom and Ari I assume
he thinks his shoulders look really good
in this picture and had some good
shoulder puns in there and that same day
Tom responded with a photo of his own
saying oh Bert your confidence is a trap
so they both use the the trap on
whenever I see you post I just shrug
better get on it for October big boy
right now you're in fourth place and
then he tagged Joe and Ari so then Ari
followed both of those pictures up with
a video of his own saying how can they
remember sobriety when they couldn't
even remember to pull out since having
kids Tom looks like Staten Island
Gandalf Burke gets obese or by the day
and Joe Rogan has become a mouthpiece
for women's sports vote fun this Autumn
vote Ari for president of sober October
so Ari with a different route for the
caption instead of the arm puns he went
just mainly uh personal Joe what do you
think Tom and I weigh in together him on
my back
thousand pounds now I said seven
thousand but it might be about how do
you still have those tits Jesus Joe
you look like the dude from [ __ ]
Guardians of the Galaxy and work out
I work out
you wear the underwear for guy who works
out hopefully we get a JRE episode with
these four soon I know that before the
Jr read sober October episodes with
these guys were some of the funniest
ones still to this day really and I'm
excited to learn what the stakes are
what the challenges are they usually
throw in a different wrinkle to make it
more entertaining for us to follow along
and I also think it's a good thing
they're doing this again just because a
lot of people I know say that they
follow along with them during sober
October and that's very healthy for them
too so good for these guys for returning
with sober October
I will not be following along but I'm
excited to watch the podcast episode
whenever that comes out I'm a stand-up
comedian Ari shaffir that reflection is
off the window behind me and not off my
scalp I am the body of a normal 41 year
old male that's right I would best
describe this thing as men
so the only way I could possibly want a
health contest is by challenging people
who are far far more out of shape than I
am Believe It or Not people who are
beaten down by the daily mental anguish
of having children it's a Non-Stop
Stress Factory these people I know
they've lived through it
so this October I want you to think not
about winning Health contests but about
surviving heart failure I'm Ari shaffir
I hope I can count on your vote this
sober October
voila
the P Cube I like it you sure do yeah
take a first spin sure get on in there
huh
there you go look at that how does that
feel feels pretty good [ __ ] the
Prototype done huh yeah you want to give
it a try oh [ __ ] that man this [ __ ]
ain't deep enough what do you mean what
are you talking about any [ __ ]
that come up to that [ __ ] with little
ass penis of course it works for them
being a big ass Johnson you gotta stand
a little further back Leo Johnson don't
overshoot hit the back of that
[ __ ] I'm not bragging this [ __ ]
but I had a lady give me a wedgie with
my own goddamn Johnson okay are we done
here HBO announced last week that Curb
Your Enthusiasm will be back for its
12th season which is fantastic news it's
one of the best comedy shows of all time
in my opinion so many great comedians
have appeared as guest actors on there
Andrew Santino Bobby Lee Doug Benson
Larry David is one of the greatest
comedians comedic writers of all time
and uh it's just great that they're
coming back for season 12. I don't know
I don't know I've looked everywhere I
have no idea I mean maybe somebody
kidnapped him No One's Gonna kidnap the
sedated dog where the [ __ ] busy Jeff
God Oscar
this is crazy
you know what what
I have a Korean bookie yeah
and he was over the house the other day
yeah
we saw Oscar they was kind of drooling
over him a little bit so he likes my dog
well
you know it's not a myth they do eat
dogs they eat dogs yeah some Koreans eat
dogs ah well you know what what I gotta
go over there now he's got a flower shop
I got to pay off my neck loss don't
shouldn't even brought it up crazy you
shouldn't have brought it up that made
me a little no no don't don't forget it
all right forgotten he didn't kidnap and
eat your dog okay
um
what are you eating son Letty this is a
fresh meat it's a quite delectable
what kind of meat
the best kind
only the best for song
so I don't know if you're aware of this
or not but uh
Oscar's missing oh that's too bad he's a
good dog
you're a dog yes yeah you won't happen
to know anything about it would you
uh no lady a new episode of protect our
Parks comes out tomorrow on The Joe
Rogan Experience which includes Rogan
Ari shafir shangillis and Mark Norman
one of the best podcast squads groups
that you can get together right now for
sure which brought me to this question
because we were just talking about the
sober October episodes and and that
whole challenge in this video so I would
like to know what you guys think sober
October podcast crew versus protect our
Parks who's more entertaining what
episodes would you rather see who would
you rather have start a permanent
podcast between the four people in the
sober October crew and the four people
in the protector Parks crew Rogan and
Ari are in both of them so you kind of
got to put up with those two characters
but interesting question
no way no way wait you don't take it
anyway
no way what are these shoes for give it
a shame give it a shame
he went too deep
oh no bro you blew your neck out there
at the back of my head yeah
my nose bleeding have you done this
before oh yeah I did it with Theo holy
dick me and Theo did it the first time
bigger nose
do you smell us different than we smell
you do you think and I eat ass podcast
guest spots from last week your mom's
house had on Louis CK two bears one cave
was Burt and Tom tiger belly had on
Harland Williams this past weekend was
Bobby Lee and Theo Von which is as
classic of a podcast Duo As It Gets In
Comedy anyone that like
tortures an animal or hurts an animal I
just I cannot I'll hang out with them
yeah but I can't get real intimate yeah
yeah man oh yeah yeah I'll go bowling
yeah I'll go bowling or like you know
what I mean we I would do like uh you
know badminton yeah you know what I mean
like a casual day on a Sunday right if
they know they torture animals but you
ain't We're not gonna have dinner around
it you know what I mean yeah we're not
gonna do it yeah three course a meal
yeah I'll do a spot with them or I'll
tour maybe would you tour with that guy
I mean you're kind of doing a lot with
them yeah yeah no but you I wouldn't
hang out after the tour I mean he's like
hey you want to go look for girls and
I'll be now I'm going to do my own thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm not gonna be in
a photo with them yeah no photo yeah
yeah what's worse people are animals
I mean I've met a lot of people I say
probably animals that's worse to me
because they have no like people have
choices
like don't burn me yeah you know what I
mean but the you know a dog can go
cuckoo yeah is that what a dog if he
does that dog's racist dude I'll tell
you that whatever yeah that's better
right yeah yeah that's an owl yeah right
that's a racist
dude if if I walk by an owl and he did
that I'd probably get mad bro you would
die loud
The Joe Rogan Experience had an
incredible week last week talking to
Aaron Rodgers and Mark Zuckerberg I
listened to both those episodes in full
and they are both very entertaining and
insightful whiskey Ginger had on Chad
and JT but he manoir was on the Honeydew
and flagrant talked to canoe as far as
new stand-up specials go there's not too
much to report on Yusuf Tim Dylan on
Netflix from a few weeks ago and Sam
Morrell's Netflix special comes out on
Thursday we're going to be doing a video
recapping the fans reactions to that
special so be sure to watch out on our
community page so you can be involved in
that video we did one for Tim Dylan
special 2 that you can watch right here
this has been another episode of the
joke World comedy update thank you so
much for watching please remember to
subscribe to joke world listen to this
episode on Spotify download it follow us
there and check out our Instagram if you
want some more daily comedy content
foreign
[Music]